>> Greg: WHAT ARE THESE MAYORS
PRETENDING WHEN THEY CUT POLICE
SPENDING, YET THEY SLASH POLICE
BUDGETS BUT THEIR OWN PROTECTION
THEY DECIDED TO BUDGET.
THIS ONE WILL BUSINESS YOU OFF,
TOO, ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT
FROM FORBES MAGAZINE, DON'T MISS
THIS YEAR'S SWIM SUIT ISSUE, THE
COVER HAS STEWART VARNY IN A
THONG.
MAYORS AND OTHER OFFICIALS IN
CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
DEFUNDED THE POLICE WHILE
SPENDING MILLIONS ON SECURITY
DETAILS ON THEMSELVES.
IN IN THEIR DEFENSE IT'S GOTTEN
REALLY DANGEROUS LATELY.
THE ONE THING THE IN COMMON
THEY'RE BEING RUN INTO THE
GROUND BY DEMOCRATIC MAYORS.
A FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT
WAS.
IN CHICAGO, HOME OF MURDER, THE
CITY SPENT 3.4 MILLION FOR 22
OFFICERS LAST YEAR TO GUARD
UNNAMED CITY OFFICIALS.
BALTIMORE SPENT 3.6 MILLION FOR
14 COPS TO COVER THE MAYOR, THE
STATE'S ATTORNEY AND THE POLICE
COMMISSIONER.
AND IN FS THE CITY SPENT 2.6 TO
PROTECT MAYOR LON DONE AGREED.
SO SHE'S PROTECTED OF COURSE THE
STORES AREN'T.
HERE'S TWO DUDES CASUALLY
WALKING OUT OF A TJ MAX IN LA
WITH ARMS FULL OF CRAFT.
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE BOARDING A
FLIGHT.
IF THEY GOT ANY MORE RELAXED AND
YOU WOULD HAVE TO CARRY THEM AS
WELL.
A NEW LAW MAKES LESS THAN 900
BUCKS OF STUFF A MISDEMEANOR
INSTEAD OF FELONY.
HERE'S THE HUMAN HAIR STYLE
GAVIN NEWSOME TODAY ON HIS
CRUMBLING STATE.
>> THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
SAY SOME OF THE POLICIES
CHAMPIONED BY DEMOCRATS LIKE
PROP 47 AND OTHERS ARE MAKING
CRIME WORSE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT.
>> THE EVIDENCE DOESN'T BACK IT
UP.
LAST THREE DECADES WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE OF CRIME IN THE STATE.
YOU'RE SEEING CRIME INCREASE IN
RED STATES THAT HAD NO CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM COMMENSURATE WITH
THE CRIME RATES WE'RE SEEING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Greg: HMM.
SOMETHING TELLS ME IF YOU STOP
CONSIDERING CRIMES WORTH
PURSUING, OF COURSE YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A DOCUMENTED DECLINE IN
CRIME.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT DOCUMENTING
IT.
THE FACT IS THERE'S MORE
SUBSTANCE IN THAT GUY'S HAIR
THAN WHAT'S UNDERNEATH IT.
>> YES
>> Greg: EMILY, DO THESE MAYORS
AND LEADERS DESERVE SECURITY IF
THEY DENY IT FOR OTHERS?
>> NO.
YOU GUYS, IN SEATTLE, MAYOR
DURKIN, SHE HAS TWO DETAILS THAT
PROTECT HER, A UNIFORMED
DIVISION AND THEN WHATEVER SORT
OF COMES WITH BEING A MAYOR.
SHE HAS A $7.5 MILLION HOUSE.
AND HERE'S THE THING.
OF THAT UNIFORMED DETAIL, THE
REGULAR OFFICERS OF SEATTLE, THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE
PRECINCT IF ONE CALLS OUT SICK
THEY PRIORITIZE HER DETAIL, THEY
WON'T TAKE COPS AWAY FROM THAT.
SO IT LEAVES THE ACTUAL
PRECINCTS AND PROTECTING OF
CITIZENS EVEN MORE LEAN THAN
DEFENDING DOES.
AND MY FIFTH QUOTE BECAUSE
THERE'S NO CELL SERVICE
APPARENTLY IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD
AND NO BATHROOM.
SO ONE COP SAID, YOU JUST SIT
THERE AND STARE AND THINK ABOUT
HOW [BLEEP] YOUR LIFE IS FOR
FOUR OR FIVE HOURS.
END QUOTE.
SO THE RESIDENT SOCIALIST PSYCHO
OF THE CITY COUNCIL LED A
PROTEST UP TO THE MAYORS HOUSE
SAYING THEY NEEDED EVEN MORE
COMMUNISM IN THE CITY SO THEN IT
GOT REAL THE MAYOR CAME OUT
CALLED IT A RIOT AND THEN THEY
SUED EACH OTHER SO IT WAS CRAZY
INFIGHTING.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR FRONT
DOOR IS ONLY WHEN THE MAYORS
PROTECT.
I HAVE TO SAY ADAM IS THE GUY
BEHIND FINDING ALL THIS STUFF
OUT AND IS CONSTANTLY EXPOSING
THE GOVERNMENT'S PAYMENTS AND
EVERYTHING, THE PAYROLL AND ALL
THE NUMBERS, EVERYWHERE THAT OUR
TAX DOLLARS GO, AND THAT'S THE
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY THAT WE
WILL NEVER UNDER GET FROM THAT
WHITE STONE MAUSOLEUM OR HOWEVER
YOU SAID IT.
>> I FELT I JUST WATCHED AN
EPISODE OF REAL HOUSE WIVES OF
SEATTLE.
>> YES
>> Greg: RIGHT?
I GOT ONE CHUCKLE OUT OF THAT.
OUR AUDIENCE IS ON DRUGS.
>> I GOT A CHUCKLE BECAUSE SHE
PRETTY MUCH DESCRIBED MY ENTIRE
BODYGUARD CAREER.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME LOOKING IN
THE REARVIEW MIRROR GOING YOU
ARE BETTER THAN THIS.
>> YES.
>> YOU'RE WATCHING SOMEONE ELSE
LIVE THEIR LIFE AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
YES, THERE'S A MOMENT WHERE YOU
THROW SOMEONE DOWN THE STAIRS
AND YES, THERE'S A MOMENT WHERE
YOU GET TO BEAT PEOPLE UP.
FOR THE MOST PART, THOUGH, IT'S
YOU STARING IN A MIRROR GOING, I
HAD A PLAN.
>> BUT THE MOVIE, THE MOVIE --
>> IT'S LIKE FEEING THE MARINE
CORPS.
>> YEAH, THAT'S NOT REAL.
NO ONE SLEEPS WITH THE BODYGUARD
UNLESS THEY'RE REALLY MENTALLY
DESTROYED
>> Greg: PATTY HEARST. MARRIED
HER BODYGUARD.
>> THEY ALL DO.
NOT THE JOBS I GOT.
>> Greg: SNOOP DIDN'T FALL IN
LOVE WITH YOU.
>> SNOW, SNOOP DIDN'T FALL IN
LOVE WITH ME OR -- THE POINT OF
THE SHOW IS NOT TO CALL ME OUT.
I'M THE EXPERT.
SNIFF YOU NEED A BODYGUARD?
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED --
>> YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE.
>> NO ONE EVER FELL UNTIL LOVE
IN THE BODYGUARD JOB EXCEPT
KEVIN COSTNER AND HE'S KEVIN
[BLEEP] COSTNER, WHO WOULDN'T
FALL IN LOVE WITH HIM
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE HE ITS
GORGES.
>> AND YOU ARE ALL RACIST FOR
CALLING ME OUT ON OBVIOUSLY MY
ISSUE OF NEVER BEING LOVED AS A
BODYGUARD.
SHAME ON YOU ALL.
>> Greg: JOEY YOU SAID YOU'RE
GOING TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHY
IT'S GREAT TO BE A POLITICIAN.
>> YOU SAID RUN.
SORRY.
>> Greg: SORRY.
YOU GET ELECTED TO BECOME IMMUNE
TO THE LAWS YOU ENACT.
IT'S FALLING APART PFRJTS I'M
RUNNING RIGHT NOW.
THERE I AM, I'M RUNNING, THAT'S
ALL THE RUNNING I GOT IN ME.
I MISSED THAT QUESTION.
>> Greg: JUST SAY WHAT YOU WANT
TO SAY.
GET TO THE C BLOCK.
>> MY SECOND BIG WORD, I HAD A
THIRD ONE NOW AND I FORGOT IT.
THIS GOES RIGHT BACK TO THE
PREVIOUS ARGUMENT, RULES FOR
THEE NOT FOR ME.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> WE'LL TAKE AWAY YOUR GUNS,
TAKE AWAY YOUR FREEDOM, MAKE YOU
WEAR A OF COURSE MA, TAKE YOUR
UNIN AND GIVE IT TO SOMEONE ELSE
BUT DON'T TRY TO APPLY THE RULES
TO ME
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU GET
WHAT YOU ASKED FOR.
IF THE NEW RULE IS 950 BUCKS, IS
A GALLON OF MILK LESS THAN 950
BUCKS IN CALIFORNIA ANYMORE?
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE END
RESULT BECAUSE EVERYTHING'S
GOING TO BE PRICED ABOVE THIS
ARBITRARY THRESHOLD THAT THESE
IDIOTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
CREATED.
>> SHOPLIFTING INFLATION, IT'S
GOING TO BE A NEW FINANCIAL
TERM.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO THINK THE
DOD'S BUYING EVERYTHING.
>> THEY DON'T NEED PROCEED TEXT
THOUGH.
I THINK THEYED SHOULD USE THAT
MONEY AND PROTECT THE ELDERLY
ASIAN WOMEN
>> Greg: YES
>> SHANNON: DID YOU SEE
>> Greg: CANAL STREET SATURDAY
MORNING, GUY GOES IN PUSHES --
GUY.
>> YEAH, THE ASIAN MOM IS
PROBABLY NEVER GOING TO WAKE UP,
MUGGED IN A SUBWAY
>> Greg: AT 6:30 IN THE MORNING.
>> USE THE $23 MILLION TO
PROTECT THEM
>> Greg: STILL HAVEN'T CAUGHT
THE GUY.
>> EVERY ONE OF THEM A PISTOL.
CAN I SAY THAT?
SECOND AMENDMENT.
EVERY ONE OF US HAS THE RIGHT TO
CARRY A FIREARM.
AN ARMED SOCIETY IS A POLITE
SOCIETY.
I DON'T WANT ANYONE TO GET SHOT
BUT IF SOMEONE DOES LET IT BE
THE PERSON WHO T